today we did several important things we
adopted the concern conclusions on the
implementation of the energy union
focusing on empowering of consumers and
attracting investment in the energy
sector we also had a comprehensive
policy debate on security of energy
supply and over the working lunch the
ministers also had a very intensive and
interesting debate on the LNG and
storage strategy what regards the energy
union conclusions that member states
have really come to the agreement that
the consumers should be at the center of
the energy union and that we should
provide EU consumers both the households
and their businesses with a secure
sustainable and competitive and
affordable energy and the consumers
should feel the benefits of
implementation of all five dimensions of
the energy union there's a clear need
for more investment and resilient
sustainability and affordability of our
future energy system depends really on
the access to sufficient investment in
the energy infrastructure we have been
very active in the negotiations to
ensure the diversification of energy
supplies to europe and the commissioner
himself has been very very active and
and that lately and I think that this
level of determination gives a strong
signal that the U is on the right the
right way to strengthening its energy
security the Commission will now focus
on four key priorities first we need to
continue to diversify our energy sources
suppliers and routes and that means
focuses on new infrastructure projects
secondly on the back of the stress test
we will propose a revision of the
security of gas supply regulation and
make proposals from common crisis
management at regional and European
Union level and we will also develop an
LNG and storage strategy thirdly next
year we will propose a revision to the
rules of the transparency of
intergovernmental agreements and lastly
we will focus on producing the man
through energy efficiency and increasing
the share of renewables in our energy
system